so a verdict has come down in the case
involving Jonathan major who has been
playing Kang the Conqueror in the MCU he
has been found guilty in two out of four
charges he was found guilty of Reckless
assault and Reckless harassment now as
soon as that guilty verdict was
announced Disney and Marvel said that he
was not being included in any future MCU
products it happened with such speed
that it's very clear that whatever
conversations were had about whether or
not to keep him were had some time ago
and they had already come to the
conclusion that if a guilty verdict came
down they were dropping him and they
have done immediately for my purposes
and what I tend to talk about the
lingering question is what do they do
with Kang now do they drop the storyline
completely or do they recast recasting
is an option given the way the
characters been done and clearly he was
planning to be a very big deal for my
money though it's more likely that they
take the opportunity to just scrap this
completely people were not getting
excited about Kang the way that they had
hoped and I think they'll take the
chance to reset with I don't know Dr
Doom